[Music]
whatever
welcome to the fox 35 sports zone i'm
adam shatoff the special olympic games
kick off this weekend in orlando and the
torch has been making
hey man
what are you doing this weekend i know
of this cool sports sporting event going
on in my town
its way across the state the final run
hit the track at daytona today sports
reporter jessica ealy has the story did
they also when they were when they were
running around the track in daytona were
they making race car noises with their
mouth
did you see the uh the the brooklyn
marathon people a few weeks back
like one of them just collapsed and died
and a bunch of other ones were went to
the hospital oh yeah yeah all the heart
attacks i didn't see it but i did read
about it i did read about it perfectly
healthy 30 year old runner just died at
the finish line
about 5 500 coaches and athletes will be
in orlando for the u.s
no frozen too dark for merch special
olympic games this week somebody doesn't
pass the test
uh
i mean we're almost to we're already an
hour and a half into the show pull her
up just for just in case i don't know
how many more stories we're gonna do
all right frozen good luck i mean i i
doubt she's going to be great but i mean
we're not working with a little bit
today just google only black news
reporter in daytona
that should come up okay
it's fox 35 new london nn
skins took a run around the 2.5 mile
track here at wait wait did they say her
name
that was very quick though wasn't it
yeah it just popped up very fast
well they didn't want her to get stolen
and they didn't wanna no that's not adam
shatoff
yeah and it's not dan newlin either i'm
pretty sure she's not dan newland no
track here at daytona international
speedway as part of the traditional
torch runs final leg i don't know she
might have potential
okay exclaim of hope made its way to
base pit vipers based to daytona
international speedway as part of its
final leg tour it's to help build
excitement for sunday's opening
ceremonies really really exciting
driving here you know the building so
hey mercy did you get my invite throwing
a little party for the special olympics
watch party that i'm doing we should do
that it'll be great a little special
like not even like for the show just do
that in real life and have a group of
friends over and be like yeah we're
watching special olympics
you guys want to come by we're going to
have like you know barbecue some chips
hold up to come to run at daytona i like
that he goes it was exciting driving
here nobody's ever said that driving to
daytona beach ever i wonder if you could
bet on this on my bookie
you should be able to the special
olympics you feel like you should right
it's still the sport
i don't think anybody slept on the bus
coming here
you mentioned your gamble someone's
gambling problem gets so bad
that they start betting on the special
olympics yeah dude i got the look i got
a little bit of money on the one with
the big tongue which i like
the back which one
look look put me uh 5 000 down uh
on a money line bet on the guy that uh
looks like one of the dudes from the
specials okay well there you go
enforcement and special olympic athletes
took one lap around the trioval before
crossing the finish line to the sounds
of cheers it's an honor like just to
carry it to start off the games
wait this is a special olympic athlete
you're not [ __ ] you're just like
european no no no that accent hold on
i'm listening to that accent i'm i he
looks he looks she looks [ __ ] like
irish fear but he sounds like
it's an honor like just to carry to
start off the games
he's hispanic some way i don't know what
kind yet though you know this is also my
first time doing it too and never done
it david rams is one of thousands of
athletes competing next week he'll try
to metal and shot put in the 4x4 the
games feature 19 olympic styles the
weightlifting seems unfair right it
feels like they're going to be stronger
than even the regular ones
i suppose yeah a lot of not a lot of
weight
no no that's
that's how little that guy is
team and individual sports in 30
different events it only happens once
every four years tonight there's 4 500
athletes who are packing their bags
and athletes
full of gummy worms and pennies
and all kinds of other assorted things i
keep saying
one year they should book the special
olympics tournament in iceland
believed that their sons and their
daughters would be competing they'll
never do that because what happens if
they break containment
jurassic park
officers who participated in the nearly
two-week torch run that spanned several
states they formed a special bond it's
amazing it's amazing like
i like we're not just
torture runners we're family now the
special olympic games that guy seems not
[ __ ] right
i don't know if he's the [ __ ] one i
mean he might be with the [ __ ] one
are we just letting foreigners now yeah
no it's cities maybe athletes are we
just letting you know they're casting
some office [ __ ] no
they think i'm slow cause i'm from
canada i thought the [ __ ] was the one
on the right
no
you're right you're right i like we're
we're not just
torch runners we're family now the
special olympia
he just sounds like he sounds somebody
she's hispanic he sounds like someone
that i would talk to in a sedano's and
[ __ ] hialeah yeah you know i it seems
like a guy you would have a nice
conversation with at the gym yeah i
don't
i kind of yeah actually that machine the
other day it was like broken too yeah i
don't know man i i don't know when
they're gonna fix it hold on a second
i'm not gonna let this go is this guy
johnny knox filling people
i feel like are you johnny knox filming
people i feel like he's not [ __ ] he
doesn't seem [ __ ] in any way
it's it's it's odd it's very sus as the
kid
you hear him talking and you're like he
sounds fine again he just sounds like
every friendly dude you'd meet at the
gym yeah you know what i mean like oh
hey are you using that machine right now
no no no no man i'm using this oh okay
cool man
you know this is also my first time
doing it too or never done it david rams
is one of thousands of athletes
competing actually sounds like every
dude works at my gym
shot put in the 4x4 the games feature
19. hold on a second he might be you
know what marsh we have to pay attention
a couple things
nobody's running the way he's running
the way he raves yeah yeah hello
but maybe he's again
he doesn't sound [ __ ] so i feel like
he's just doing the bit
he's competing next week i think he's
doing that shot put in the 4x4
yeah but any one of us could do that
right you and i could join the special
olympics and go hello
and then just dominate these cards
19 olympic style team and individual
sports and 30 different events let's see
let's do it let's let's sign up for uh
special olympic basketball
and i mean i don't want to join the wnba
and let's just foul these [ __ ]
by the way did you see danny paultruck
special yes dude the international jew
yes
he closed with a very funny bit bro he's
so funny dude like he's such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] stirrer
like he's very manipulative you know
what i mean well because he's jewish um
but the way he makes a crowd turn on him
like when he was talking about the wnba
and just lowering the goal like lowering
the [ __ ] the basket
and how the crowd was like oh and he's
like why does everyone always react that
way they're literally shorter and they
don't score in these games why would you
not lower the thing why is it a bad like
he just broke down why everyone's like
immediately is resistant to that and
it's like
but you guys are not scoring in this
game why don't you bring the thing down
and then he had some good line about
doing like uh
you know the uh wnba slam dunk contest
and he's like who wouldn't want to watch
those big giant women like slam dunking
on one of those kids fisher price well
it's funny he was doing his low value
mail podcast we should check out it's
really good and uh i happen to be in the
chat room at the same time as alex stein
so alex stein called in screaming like
normal about the wnba and um
i hop i hopped on and i was always
telling him i said listen i don't want
you and that [ __ ] alex stein to
normalize wnba as being cool do you hear
me like you guys are playing a dangerous
game with that
yeah i love it stein's always bringing
up the wnba
yeah he's a [ __ ] weirdo he's the type
of guy you know probably knows more
about the wnba than he should
he could probably name more than two
teams which alone if you're a guy
that's too much can we look that guy up
i wanna alex stein he's been on the show
not him the [ __ ]
the the fake [ __ ] i want to
investigate this guy also uh verdict
we need to audit the special olympics
wait the listen the fed can wait
no we need to respect the fed but we
need to hold
because i don't trust that guy i love i
love how you got there with that why
they
all right man